et voilà nous sommes bien arrivés en
angleterre
vous êtes nombreux à nous avoir dit que
cet échange de maison était une mauvaise
idée
on va vous prouver que vous avez tort
bon d'accord il m'a convaincu javier
rester bien sûr que ça va aller tout
seul oui faire
l'atmosphère est oppressante maison à 1
puis tranche
c'est quoi ça est-ce qu'il vous est déjà
arrivé de remarquer d'étranges
phénomènes dîner a l'impression que nous
ne sommes pas seuls on a fait changé
toutes les serrures vous avez aussi les
caméras alors vous observé depuis le
début
y'a quelqu'un bat quel genre de problème
vu quelqu'un entre dans cette maison par
effraction je vais en toucher un mot à
mon supérieur essayé de bien faire
attention à fermer toutes les fenêtres
ou des portes aussi la seule chose qu'on
n'est pas encore testé c'est ça on veut
récupérer notre maison nous avons signé
un contrat pour six mois
nous comptons bien rester ici va falloir
vous y faire
matin
ce n'aurait pas dû nous faire venir ici
et dis moi que ce qui se passe afin de
questionner démarre la voiture
génie